so on the solaris side sena soflam this
kind of idea of there being
intelligences out there that are
different than our own do you think
their intelligences may be all around us
that were not able to even detect so
this kind of idea of maybe you can
comment also on Stephen Wolfram thinking
that there's computations all around us
and we're just not smart enough to kind
of detect their intelligence or
appreciate their intelligence yes so my
friend Hugo de garis who I've been
talking to about these things for many
decades since the early 90s he had an
idea he called sipi the search for an
interim particulate intelligence so the
concept there was as a eyes get smarter
and smarter and smarter
you know assuming the laws of physics as
we know them now are still are still
what these super intelligence is
perceived holding are bound by as they
get smarter and smarter they're gonna
shrink themselves littler and littler
because special relativity makes makes
it snow so the communicate between two
spatially distant points so they're
gonna get smaller and smaller but then
ultimately what does that mean the minds
of the super super super intelligences
they're going to be packed into the the
interaction of elementary particles or
quarks or the Parton's inside quarks or
whatever it is
so what we perceive as random
fluctuations on the quantum or sub
quantum level may actually be the
thoughts of the micro micro micro
miniaturized super intelligences because
there's no way we can tell random from
structured but with an algorithmic
information more complex in our brains
right we can't tell the difference so
what we think is random could be the
thought processes of some really tiny
super Minds and if so there's not a damn
thing we can do about it except you know
try to upgrade our intelligences and
expand our mind so that we can we can
perceive more of what's around this but
if the if those random fluctuations like
if even if we go to like quantum
mechanics if that if that's actually
super intelligent systems aren't we then
part of the soup of super intelligence
the word aren't we just like like a
finger of the entirety of the body of
the super intelligent system I mean a
finger is a is a strange metaphor I mean
I think here's Damas I mean as Papa the
finger is also useful and it's
controlled with with intent but by the
brain worse we may be much less than
that right I mean I mean yeah we may be
just some random epiphenomena land that
they don't care about too much like
think about the the shape of the crowd
emanating from a sports stadium or
something right there there's some
emergent shape to the crowd it's there
you could take a picture of it it's kind
of cool it's irrelevant the main point
of the sports event or where the people
are going or what's on the minds of the
people making that shape in the crowd
right so we we may just be some semi
arbitrary higher level pattern popping
out of a lower-level
hyper-intelligent self-organization and
I mean so so be it right I mean that's
one thing there's still fun ride yeah I
mean the older I've gotten the more
respect I've achieved for our
fundamental ignorance I mean mine and
everybody else's I mean I look at my my
two dogs two beautiful little toy
poodles and you know they watch me
sitting at the computer typing they just
think I'm sitting there wiggling my
fingers to exercise and maybe or
guarding the monitor on the desk that
they have no idea that I'm communicating
with other people halfway around the
world let alone you know creating
complex algorithms running in RAM on
some computer server in st. Petersburg
or something right that although they're
right there they're right there in the
room with me so what things are there
right around us that were just too
stupid or close mountain to comprehend
probably probably quite a lot you're
very you're very poodle could be could
also be communicating across multiple
dimensions with with other or other
beings in your - you're too
unintelligent to understand the kind of
communication mechanism they're going
through there there there have been
various TV shows and science fiction
novels positing cats dolphins mice and
whatnot
actually super intelligence is here to
observe that I would I would guess as
one or the other quantum physics
founders said those theories are not
crazy enough to be true the realities
beautifully put
you